HOLIDAY SALES.
>> Mike: RICH EDISON, THANKS A
LOT.
DURING CELEBRATIONS TODAY, TAKE
A MOMENT TO REMEMBER THAT
CHRISTMAS DAY IS NOT JOYOUS FOR
ALL.
THE REMAINS OF A NEW JERSEY
GREEN BERET KILLED IN
AFGHANISTAN RETURNED TO AMERICAN
SOIL TODAY AND WHAT IS CALLED A
DIGNIFIED TRANSFER.
THE FAMILY OF THE FALL AND AGREE
TO HAVE THE MEDIA COVER THE
EVENT.
LUCAS TOMLINSON REPORTS ON THE
PENTAGON ON THE SOLEMN OCCASION.
>> THE REMAINS OF SERGEANT FIRST
CLASS MICHAEL GOEBEL RETURNED TO
DOVER AIR FORCE BASE ON
CHRISTMAS MORNING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR ROBERT O'BRIEN
AND CHAIRMAN OF JOINTS CHIEFS OF
STAFF WERE AMONG THOSE HONORING
HIM.
THE 33-YEAR-OLD NEW JERSEY
NATIVE IS THE 20TH AMERICAN
KILLED IN COMBAT THIS YEAR.
HE RECEIVED FOUR BRONZE STARS.
SERGEANT FIRST CLASS GOBLE
LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE JAN AND
DAUGHTER ZOE.
THE DEFENSE SECRETARY SAYS THAT
UNITED STATES WILL NEVER LET
AFGHANISTAN BECOME A SAFE HAVEN
FOR TERRORISTS.
>> UNTIL WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
THAT MISSION IS COMPLETE, WE
WILL RETAIN A PRESENCE TO DO
THAT.
>> 13,000 U.S. TROOPS REMAIN IN
AFGHANISTAN AND THE HEIGHT OF
U.S. MILITARY INVOLVEMENT IN
2010 OVER 100,000 DEPLOYED THERE
AS PART OF THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
SEARCH.
IF YOU TROOPS COULD SPEND NEXT
CHRISTMAS IN AFGHANISTAN AS THE
PRESIDENT PULLS NEARLY 4,000
TROOPS OUT, AND EVEN MORE FROM
OTHER HOT SPOTS.
>> I'M LOOKING AT CENTCOM, ALL
THOSE PLACES WHERE WE CAN FREE
UP TROOPS.
AND THEN REALLOCATE THEM, TO
COMPETE WITH THE CHINESE.
>> WITH ONLY 7,000 U.S. TROOPS
DEPLOYED TO AFRICA DEFENSE
OFFICIALS SAY THERE'S NOT MANY
TRIPS TO CUT.
EARLIER THIS MONTH AHEAD OF U.S.
FORCES IN AFRICA, AND THIS YEAR
U.S. FORCES WILL HAVE LAUNCHED A
RECORD NUMBER OF DRONE STRIKES